est avec nous sur ce plateau
bonsoir alors vous êtes coach de vie et
et de finan c'est qu'en clair je vous
explique l'inflation l'envolet des prix
le gouvernement qui a présenté son
projet de budget 2024 évidemment les
mois qui qui vont suivre vont être un
peu compliqué on le sait les prix de
l'énergie mais qu'est-ce qui manque pas
en fait aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui ne
grimpe pas les étiquettes s'envolent
partout on a besoin de vous on a besoin
de vos conseils pour essayer de faire
des économies substantielles parce que
franchement on s'en sort pas et ça
concerne ça concerne absolument
absolument tout le
monde regardez on vous a préparé un
petit un petit reportage sur ce sujet
mais enfin on est tous concernés le
pouvoir d'achat des Français au cœur de
l'interview d'Emmanuel Macron hier soir
il y aura-t-il un un coup de pouce un
geste pour le portefeuille des Français
c'est inquiétant il en a une ha des prix
de partout j'étais à 60 € le mois
l'année dernière et là je suis à 100 €.
si on nide pas les Français comment ils
vont payer leur factur le pouvoir
d'achat était je sais bien il est est
agressé ce pouvoir d'achat mais il est
quand même très soutenu par le
gouvernement aujourd'hui le bouclier
tarifaire sur les prix de l'électricité
va prendre fin progressivement votre
facture va donc augmenter en 2024 voilà
les Français qui voilà non mais c'est
incroyable parce que les salaires
augmentent pas aussi vite que les prix
bien sûr donc ça c'est c'est un
véritable problème est-ce que vous avez
beaucoup de personnes laence qui
viennent vous voir pour vous demander
des des conseils quel type de conseils
on vous demande oui ben on me demande
avant tout des conseils pour se sentir
mieux hein parce que la première chose
qui se passe c'est l'angoisse qui monte
on voit les personnes on parle d'AG pr
l'inquiétude monte et moi la première
chose que je veux dire c'est qu'en effet
on est dans une situation de crise on le
subit tous et là on a un choix on a une
opportunité peut-être et bien de cesser
de subir en s'intéressant à quelque
chose auquel on ne s'intéresse peut-être
pas forcément et suffisamment dans nos
vies qui s'appelle l'argent ou un sujet
qui gratte un sujet qu'on aime pas
aborder bah oui mais encore faut-il le
problème c'est que les Français se
retrouvent à la fin du mois enfin même à
la fin du mois quand c'est la fin du
mois c'est déjà une chose mais c'est
souvent le 15 du mois le 5 du mois et
enfin c'est c'est absolument plus
possible il va falloir trouver des des
des solutions et vous en avez peut-être
peut-être des solutions à nous proposer
à proposer à ceux qui nous qui nous
regardent comment faire pour arriver à
gérer son budget d'une manière peut-être
un peu différente en temps de crise
alors je vais vous donner six grands
principes six grands principes que qui
sont un peu une sorte de condensé de
résumé et si on y fait attention on peut
arriver à améliorer la situation il y a
pas de solution miracle hein il é
primond bon mais on peut quand même
améliorer sa situation et surtout se S
mieux avec son argent après si on veut
aller plus loin on peut aussi bien mon
petit bouquin j'arrête de finir le moi
découvert support votre votre livre ou
voilà on peut aller plus loin avec ça il
y a des exercices dedans et ça nous aide
aussi à nous pencher sur comment on se
on se relie à cette énergie dans notre
vie qui est l'argent alors d'abord vous
dites qu'il faut compter alors il faut
compterou alors c'està-dire ouais
compter c'est l'hygiène financière quand
on se brosse les dents régulièrement
c'est pour éviter d'avoir à aller en
urgence chez son dentiste B quand on
fait ses comptes régulièrement c'est
pour éviter d'avoir à aller en urgence
chez son banquier c'est la base de la
base s'intéresser à son budget tous les
jours faire ses pointer s pas des
app voilà ça c'est c'est mais c'estàdire
il y a pas des applis pour n alors il y
a des applis mais on n'est pas tous égau
par rapport à faire ses comptes il y a
des mateux des gens qui sont comptables
des gens pour qui ça va pas être un
problème et puis il y a des personnes
pour qui ça peut être une véritable
angoisse des rêveurs des artistes des
gens qui ont pas du tout l'habitude de
ça j'en fais partie et pourtant j'ai
appris à faire ça alors les deux grands
conseils que je donne pour ça c'est
d'abord choisir un til qui nous va parce
qu'une appli ça va aller pour pour un
geek pour quelqu'un qui maîtrise bien ça
mais quelqu'un qui est pas très à l'aise
finalement avec l'informatique peut-être
que comme pour moi qui suis plutôt une
littéraire un petit carnet un petit
stylo pour noter ses dépenses dépense un
paquet de chumgum on le note par exemple
oui ah pas mal von
c'est parce que vous allez commencer à
faire attention au détail à faire
attention à cet argent et le soir l'air
de rien de paquet de chemgum en petit
coup à boire en ceci vous allez voir à
quel point vous avez on est déprimé en
fait ce soir on est déprimé c'est ce que
vous dites rentrer à la maison fait non
mais le
M mais moi je fais ça sur mon agenda
tous les jours je note ce que j'ai
dépensé dans la journée et m de rien PAF
ben ça te met dans la tête ce que tu
dépenses et tu fais ta petite somme j'ai
une vie de merde en ce moment non à la
fin de la semaine à la fin de la semaine
tu fais un petit total et du coup ça te
met dans la tête ce que tu as dépensé et
du coup tu prends conscience de tes
dépens conscience de ça et ça permet
pour ça angoisse
pardon alors je vais vous dire je vais
vous donner une astuce pour justement
dépasser cette angoisse au moment de
faire ses comptes on va essayer d'en
faire un moment zen alors je vais vous
dire des choses complètement
contreintuitif mais moi quand je fais
mes comptes je range bien mon bureau je
mets une petite musique chill je me
prends mon petit ch mais quand on ne
range pas chez soi aussi on fait comment
faut commcer par
ranger ah ou d'accord
il un peu se dire qu'on va prendre
rendez-vous avec son argent comme si on
avait rendez-vous avec un amoureux un
petit peu quand même on fait quelque
chose parce quein de son argent c'est
prendre soin de soi ou oui mais ça vous
AZ
raison mon je vous
avoue salut tu demander
quoi alors conseil numéro 2 Laurence
fini les fuites d'argent c'est-àdire
fini les fuites d'argent compter ça nous
aide à regarder tout ce qui fait une
fuite d'argent bah c'est un petit peu
comme une fuite d'eau dans votre système
de plomberie hein c'est un tuyau caché
qu' un trou vous le voyez pas et puis
l'air de rien bah ça sonne votre facture
ça ça augmente votre facture d'eau ben
nous c'est pareil vous avez sur vos
comptes si vous faites pas votre
pointage régulièrement des abonnements à
un magazine que vous n'utilisez plus
vous savez
les fameuses c'est de être attentif les
fameuses applis on vous dit le premier
mois gratuit on vous demande votre carte
bleue et c'est parti donc ce genre de
chose hein donc ça faut faire attention
c'est le moment de repasser au CRIP vos
contrats d'assurance vos contrats de
fournisseur et de vérifier si vous
pouvez pas trouver mieux chez la
concurrence ou bien si vous avez pas des
garanties donc vous nvez plus besoin qui
augmente aussi la facture tout ça c'est
le moment de le faire et puis il y a
d'autres formes de fuite alors ça c'est
pas des fuites d'argent direct mais ça
peut être les fuites d'énergie he
typiquement l'eau sous la douche ou bien
par exemple l'électricité le soir on
laisse ça par exemple aussi mais le soir
on va laisser l'ordi allumer la box
allumé la télé allumer l'enttin
Bluetooth toutes les petits LED rouges
le soir si on éteint tout qu'on coupe on
débranche donc fa aller chercher chaque
truc et le débrancher oui Véronique
c'est comme ça voilà il va couchez les
volet débrcher les prises mais oui ça
fait faire des économies substantielles
mais à force de tout éteindre vous êtes
pas pris beaucoup de murs parce que
alors moi depu j'te tout j'arrête pas de
prendre des portes mais j'ai une
vais
é laence quand même vous nous vendez une
soirée de rêve alors desjà condition
pour faire ses compes après on é tout
voyez plus rien vous prenez les murs
pour a des lampes de poche énergie
solaire qui existe que vous pouvez
charger pendant la journée et le soir
les avoir et sans
avoir
bien on
vousille
voilà avec la lamp front solaire la nuit
et c'est parfait voilà on va y aller
avec les allumettes c'est peut-être un
peu moins cher bon bref alors trème
conseil les enveloppes faire des
enveloppes c'est ça alors épargner
c'est-à-dire ne pas renoncer à son
épargne parce que ça peut être le moment
où évidemment on a tentation de dire on
va prendre dans nos réserves prendre
dans No réserves pour
maintenirà mais il faut pas renoncer à
garder une petite réserve et ça je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi c'est important
déjà comment on fait on va faire la loi
du pourcentage c'estàdire on gagne 1000
€ on met 100 € même 50 € de côté un peu
petit montant pas se dire qu'on va faire
des grosses économies et pourquoi ça
sert de faire quand même des petites
réserves c'est pas une grosse épargne
mais c'est l'histoire de dire j'ai quand
même quelque chose c'est pas je suis
toujours comme ça j'ai vraiment rien je
suis pas capable d'épargner vous voyez
ça nous met pas dans un bon état
d'esprit et l'état d'esprit qu'on a
c'est un essentiel pour pouvoir se
sentir bien avec l'argent donc on
préserve quand même un petit peu
d'épargne en mettant des petits montants
de côté il faut quand même savoir que
l'épargne c'est de l'argent qu'on se
donne à soi-même la dépense c'est de
l'argent qu'on distribue aux autres faut
choisir bon alors bon d'accord bon alors
on fait les petit le système du petits
cochons quoi c'est ça voilà mettre de
l'argent fr de tout quand on pe faire
aussi besoins revoir nos besoins voilà
on va voir qu'on peut toujours en fait
le faire si on arrive et c'est ça je
trouve cette opportunité quand même que
nous donne cette crise c'est de se poser
les bonnes question parce que il faut
quand même savoir que la crise et
l'inflation elle se passe dans un
contexte d'une société qui a tendance à
surconsommer V et même à être dans des
formes de dép ça veut dire des bonnes
questions c'est quoi les bonnes B
question besoin de ce que j'achète
est-ce que quand je rentre dans le
magasin j'ai tendance à acheter des fois
comme ça des gens qui laachète aigu
alors ça maladie ça c'est une vraie
maladie et je vais en parler aussi bon
on peut en parler tout de suite si vous
voulez des personnes qui ont des
dépenses compulsives donc place
émotionnelle c'est une maladie il y a
une pathologie si on veut se faire aider
pour ça alors évidemment on a le choix
d'aller voir un PS mais ça c'est encore
de l'argent qu'on dépense et sinon j'ai
quand même noté pour ces personnes et je
tenais à le dire il a une association
qui existe comme pour les alcooliqu
anonyme ça s'appelle les débiteurs
anonymes ah les débiteurs bien
gr vent vous pouvez pas vous empêcher de
dépenser et bien faites app ne restez
pas seul avec ça parce que Laurence
est-ce que la carte bleue que nous avons
tous aujourd'hui qu'on qu'on dégaine
pour une baguette de pain est-ce que ça
ça pousse pas à consommer davantage plus
avec le
S petit par par là et voilà on est tous
d'accord avec ça donc là évidemment ben
le la conseille c'est de retirer des
espèces je vais retirer 30 € je mets 30
€ dans mon porte-monnaie je laisse ma
carte bleue à la maison et je vais faire
mes courses et avec mes et je
pleure je vais être obligé de faire
attention et de n'acheter que ce que
j'ai décidé ça va m'apprendre une forme
de discipline de limite mais aussi comme
je vous disais vous me posez les bonnes
questions est-ce que j'ai vraiment
besoin de ça l'autre solution c'est le
drive ça évite de rentrer dans le
supermarché et d'être
soumis c'est c'est pas plus cher le
drive lance non ça revient pas forcément
plus cher et surtout ça revient souvent
vraiment beaucoup moins cher tout
simplement parce qu'on évite de rentrer
dans le magasin et d'êt quand on vous
propose votre shampoing préféré de
bouteilles pour prix vous allez le
prendre ah c'est mon shampo préér si
vous n'en avez pas besoin c'est trop
cher oui mais quand on vous quand vous
commandez des tomates et qu'elles sont
vertes quand on vous les sert si vous
voulez moi je préfère aller les tâer
vous voyez dans le rayon plutôt que
qu'on les ser directement c'est un gros
radin il pas envie de se faire avoir en
plus de ça non mais c'est bien d'allerir
le marché c'est une très bonne chose 5è
conseil 5è conseil Laurence récupérer
excusez excusez-moi récupérer emprunter
et recycler le R de l'économie
récupéreréconomie c'est pour dire que
des fois on a réflexe d'aller acheter
quelque chose un outil un matériel alors
qu'on pourrait par exemple l'emprunter à
son voisin qu'on peut mutualiser
beaucoup de choses même par exemple un
robot mixer dont on sert une fois dans
le mois pourquoi est-ce que finalement
on l'achèterait pas à plusieurs ce genre
de chose on peut y penser il y a
beaucoup d'association aujourd'hui y des
associations qui existent et et ça fait
du lien humain on peut se dire aussi
pourquoi pas c'est l'opportunité de
créer plus de liens humains de créer de
la richesse humaine plutôt que de
toujours aller acheter des choses est-ce
que je peux emprunter est-ce que je peux
prêter est-ce que je peux recycler
est-ce que je peux donner et recevoir il
y a aussi des sites d'association qui
permettent aujourd'hui de donner des
choses aux autres donc ça aussi c'est
s'ouvrir à cette économie un petit peu
parallèle plus humaine plus fond et ça
après tu deviens complètement accro moi
je me suis inscrit à une appli qui est
connu commence par un V qui finit par
aide et alors là je revends tout dès je
croise un truc mais je vous jure c'est
horrible dè que je croise une chaussure
je dis je vais la revendre je mets un
prix et je suis comme ça j'ai
l'impression
queant c'est amusant aussi et puis ça
peut permettre d'arrondir ses fin de
mois vous avez chez vous un objet que
vous n'utilisez pas depuis longtemps ça
sert à acheter moins cher ça sert à
créer plus de liens avec d'autres
personnes ça peut être
sympa ça permet aussi oui avec plein
d'autres choses ça permet
aussi est-ce que tu vas l'acheter
vonique je suis pas sûr alors je me
suici tout
derrièreisp ave un pe cadeau c'est
génial
conseil je vais mettre je vais m mettre
bien s tous les conseils de laenceil
développer son potentiel financier
dernier point en effet ça peut être
aussi l'opportunité cette crise de dire
finalement est-ce que j'aurais pas moi
des possibilités de donner plus au monde
de valeur et ça va m'obliger à
allerevoir les ressources que j'ai en
moi des qualités des compétences des
projets des passions que j'ai peut-être
pas exploité moi je voulais
débrousailler mon jardin j'ai fait appel
je tombe sur un monsieur qui me dit ben
je viendrai vous voir en fin de journée
parce que moi je travaille chez Renault
et le soir j'ai mon auto-entreprise de
débroussaillage voilà quelqu'un qui
baisse pas les bras qui se dit ben je
vais pouvoir créer une auto-entreprise
pour gagner aussi un peu plus d'argent
ça peut être le moment aussi de se
former comme on a toujours rêvé pour
avoir plus de compétences et passer un
poste supérieur demander une
augmentation donc cette crise peut être
aussi l'opportunité pour les personnes
d'
chercher
futurz l'idée générale si vous voulez
globale que le message global que je
veux faire passer c'est que oui c'est la
un entre guillemets mais on peut essayer
de transformer ça quand même en
or en restant positif en voyant les
opportunités qu'on a de corriger des
comports finalement qui sont pas
forcément B pour nous de nous ouvrir à
d'autres possibilités de lien avec les
autres en créant de la richesse humaine
et desbroussill par exemple
débroussailler débrousailler sa maison
aussi moi je brousaille beaucoup et
d'ailleurs j'ai débroussaillé tous mes
amis Figur vous savez pourquoi parce que
quand vous vous engueulez avec tout le
monde au MO on vous invite plus à des
anniversaires vous n'avez pas besoin
d'acheter de cadeaux et là vous faites
des
économies derer point sur pensez que on
a tous beaucoup de valeur on a tous
beaucoup de richess en nous qu'elle soit
intérieur qu'elle soi des qualités
personnelles aussi donc il y a pas que
la richesse financière et avec cette
richesse qu'on a à l'intérieur de nous
on peut trouver aussi des
solution m merci
laence merci mais j'espère ça vous a
servi ce petit conseil on ais plein de
choses
là ce soir faut se mettre en condition
faire t malquer ce soir JEE
ut ça par contre c'est génial le côté
mettre une petite ambiance quand tu dois
faire tes comptes c'est génial tu tu
vois tous les gens qui vont être là qui
vont se mettre des petites
bougie non mais c'est pas mal dans le
coup de l'ambiance bougie j'ai
rendez-vous avec mon argent c'est super
ce soir tu fais
quoi et franchement c on l'avait jamais
fait ça j'adore non mais c'est très fort
c'est très très fort c'est très fort